it is a sight to behold my own volcano
in central Philippines is known to have
a near perfect cone owing to its
frequent eruptions its Summit has been
glowing since last week and it's been
attracting tourists
but for people who live around one of
the Philippines most active volcanoes
it's bad news on Monday scientists and
local officials confirmed lava is now
flowing down the volcano slopes an
escalation but not enough to raise the
alert level yet
those living within the six kilometer
danger zone if and when alert level 3
becomes alert level four we are mandated
to evacuate those living within uh the
seven kilometer danger zone
more than 13 000 people have already
fled their homes but what they use to
mayon's Rumblings they say they're not
taking any risks
it's better to be on the safe side
safe side sure will survive including
our children and our livestock
it looks like my own will erupt the
crater glow is a sign
government officials aren't taking any
chances either they're already preparing
to move more people
during the last eruption in 2018
preemptive evacuations prevented any
loss of life
State vulcanologists say Mayon is
already erupting but it's a quiet kind
known as effusive eruption they're
hoping it won't progress to a violent
eruption but it's too early to predict
how severe it will be Barney below Al
Jazeera The gaspi City the Philippines